boa tarde gostaria de agradecer a
oportunidade está no tek x da unicamp é
meu nome é renata ribeiro do valle
gonçalves
vou falar um pouco sobre o uso de
imagens de satélites meteorológicos para
estudos agrícolas bem o trabalho no
cepagri que é o centro de pesquisas
meteorológicas e climáticas aplicadas à
agricultura cepagri ele tem como as
áreas de atuação ecofisiologia de planta
agrometeorologia mudanças climáticas
monitoramento safras agrícolas e por fim
sensoriamento remoto que é o que eu vou
abordar hoje aqui na minha fala é então
o cepagri ele é pioneiro na unicamp
nessa parte de processamento digital de
imagens porque desde 1985 é ele adquire
um receber um receptor de imagens para
estudos meteorológicos que se denominava
uai r e depois de nove anos foi
adquirido um sistema de recepção de
imagens do satélite noa ea partir daí
nós começamos o estudo para a previsão
do tempo e estudos agrícolas
em 2004 esse sistema foi atualizado e
além do satélite novo nós passamos a
receber imagens também do satélite fang
e em 2014 do nou a e do satélite metop
agora em 2016 nós também vamos
adquirimos né um sistema da nova geração
do satélite gols r que já foi lançado
agora no último dia 19 já está em órbita
e vai ser chamado gols 16
então nós temos diversas a teles no cepa
gritam são diversas imagens pra nós
fazemos a previsão do tempo
e além disso também temos o sistema
geonet cast que será instalado agora no
próximo
nos próximos dias em dezembro
então nosso banco de imagens
principalmente do satélite noa é um
banco é que contém mais ou menos 55 mil
imagens em torno de seis internas bytes
de dados
então nós temos uma série de 9 de 1995
até hoje 2015
são imagens diárias estão o satélite
passa está em órbita ele passa por cima
da nossa antena que está instalado em
cima do prédio do cepagri edis carrega
os dados e nós trabalhamos essas imagens
normalmente para fazer estudo
metrológico e a ideia sempre foi fazer
um banco mesmo guardando todas essas
imagens estão com uma gama de informação
desse tamanho porque não utilizar para
outros tipos de estudo né então foi onde
surgiu a idéia de trabalhar para estudos
agrícolas
aqui nós temos uma imagem é exemplo do
que nós recebemos essa imagem é paixão
a nossa fé que a gente recebe a faixa
pegando o nordeste do brasil são paulo
sul e parte do centro oeste raramente
pega o norte e principalmente a amazônia
então nossa o nosso raio da antena não
supre o brasil todo mas principalmente a
nossa área de atuação agrícola a gente
pegue previsão do tempo também aqui uma
outra imagem exemplo do gol aos 13
essa imagem é nós disponibilizamos no
nosso site é de mantena que está
localizada no inpi
mas vai ser essa imagem que nós teremos
no ano que vem a cada 30 minutos
disponível no site com a previsão e
mento das massas de ar disponível pra
vocês
então como eu disse
o uso do sensoriamento remoto na
agricultura
qual é a dificuldade de utilizar essas
imagens de uso meteorológicos para a
agricultura
o grande desafio é a resolução spam
espacial dessa imagem que seria um
quilômetro por um quilômetro e qual é a
vantagem
a resolução temporal porque nós temos
imagens a cada 12 horas a cada hora ou a
cada 30 minutos como eu vai ter nesse
novo satélite dessa nova geração e
também tem um baixo custo dessas imagens
então o ideal seria mostrar o pivô 'o
que seria essa primeira imagem do lado
esquerdo onde nós temos a definição
exata das culturas agrícolas
mas a nossa realidade é essa imagem
abaixo é onde eu tenho estado todo que
seria a imagem metrológica
então como utilizar isso como fazer esse
estudo juntar à baixa resolução espacial
com baixo custo e alta temporada idade
porque o nosso ideal seria alta
resolução temporal desculpa baixa
resolução temporal mas alta resolução
espacial
só que o alto custo então nós vamos
fazer o estudo é utilizando culturas
agrícolas que tenha grandes áreas
plantadas no país e usando séries
temporais que eu vou saber qual é a
sazonalidade da cultura
então a cultura
linda é a cana-de-açúcar principalmente
no estado de são paulo que é o maior
produtor da cultura são as imagens que
nós utilizamos para fazer esse estudo
são imagens de ndv em albedo e
temperatura de superfície como que é
feito nós pegamos pontos mapeados na
cultura
extraímos esses valores pelas imagens
meteorológicas principalmente do
satélite noa
criamos um perfil temporal como mostra o
gráfico abaixo ea partir desse estudo
temporal que nós vamos fazer o
monitoramento e mapeamento da cultura no
estado de são paulo então é é um
mapeamento eo monitoramento regional não
seria um mapeamento e monitoramento
pontual de talhões no caso
nós vamos fazer um mapeamento do estado
todo
analisando somente o índice de vegetação
que é o ntv
eu tenho nesse gráfico abaixo
valores altos e valores baixos todos os
pontos aqui mapeados são cana de açúcar
o que aparecer
o que diferencia um ponto do outro seria
o estágio de desenvolvimento então tem
câncer do qual é essa sido colhida splan
tanta no seu desenvolvimento
então aqui mostra um vídeo em que vocês
vão analisar os pontos em vermelho eu
tenho valores cnbv que o índice de
visitação ao tupi isso significa que eu
tenho cana no campo e pontos é roxo os
azuis que significam cana que já foi
colhida
então eu consigo visualizar a dinâmica
da cana ao longo do ano
aqui eu tenho são os meses maio junho
julho e aí eu consigo visualizar agora
agosto a cana já está sendo colhida mais
pontos em azul em dezembro quando a cana
volta se desenvolveu tenho pontos maior
quantidade em vermelho e assim
sucessivamente eu consigo ver a dinâmica
da cultura ao longo do ano estão
analisando os gráficos
eu tenho a sazonalidade em que cada ano
então é uma série de dez anos onde nos
meses de julho agosto setembro outubro
os valores de índices de vegetação são
mais baixos
conforme vai passando o tempo esses
valores vão subindo então quer dizer que
a cana está se desenvolvendo e assim
sucessivamente durante todos os anos
aqui eu estou analisando dados de
temperatura de superfície e dados de
índice de vegetação percebam que quando
o índice de vegetação é maior
a minha temperatura do solo é menor e
quando o índice de vegetação é menor
a temperatura do solo é maior então eu
consigo analisar com técnicas de
mineração de dados e técnicas
estatística
esses dados ao longo do tempo tão sérios
temporais de imagens com mineração de
dados eu consigo fazer um mapeamento e
monitoramento da cana de açúcar
então eu mostro esses dois mapas uma apa
de 2001 eo mapa de 2010 em que eu faço o
mapeamento da cana e de outros alvos no
estado todo como as áreas de mata que
aparece aparecem no mapa e vermelho as
áreas de cana-de-açúcar ela são os
pontos em amarelo
os pontos em azul são áreas com
vegetação rasteira ou o solo nu e as
áreas em roxo são áreas de água e áreas
urbanas
então é concluindo o uso de imagens de
satélites meteorológicos que são uns até
imagens de baixa resolução espacial são
úteis para o monitoramento de safras de
cana de açúcar porque analisa uma série
temporal de dados onde eu sei a
sazonalidade da cultura e analiso
índices de vegetação e em e temperatura
de superfície e com isso eu consigo
mapear e ver como é a dinâmica da
cultura no campo através dessas pedras
desse uso de imagens meteorológicas
gostaria de agradecer a atenção de vocês
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]